there's a big double standard at the
white house when it comes to
smoking marijuana the biden
administration firing five staffers over
their past
pot use but what about kamala harris who
said this on the campaign trail
have you ever smoked i have okay and i
and i inhaled i didn't i did it
it was a long time ago can you remember
to hide
i do so if it was legalized all
throughout the country and
medicinal would you you know do it
listen i think that it gives a lot of
people joy
and we need more people
okay so i'll start with you
jesse i mean it is against the law
the federal law to be in possession of
marijuana
and uh but not in 14 states
so the issue is for this white house are
now saying they've let five people go
what if you smoked marijuana in a state
where it was
not illegal should they be fired
well i assumed that everybody working at
the white house
was high i mean how do you explain their
behavior
kamala harris is cracking up
hysterically all of the time
joe biden's so paranoid he won't even
leave the white house to talk to
reporters
he was tripping really hard on friday
they're making the cartels filthy rich
and they want everybody to stay inside
their homes and order delivery
you're saying that they're sober at the
white house i don't buy it
okay all right so dana what about the
idea of
uh firing people for past marijuana use
so i'm confused i'm a little bit
confused by this because um
one it would be you have to fill out a
form called sf86
and like if you lie on the form then i
could see
maybe firing them but i also don't
understand why they had to announce this
if these five people are going to be let
go because they weren't going to be able
to
get their clearance then or they pass
their background check then
let them go but why have to announce it
because they look like such hypocrites
they tripped over themselves
to talk about how they wanted to
legalize marijuana all through the
campaign and if you remember tulsi
gabbard
had that like her best debate
performance one of them was going after
kamala harris for locking up i think
however many people she locked up when
she was at state attorney general
for smoking marijuana so there is a big
conundrum because the federal government
and the state governments
are not matching up and they have an
opportunity to fix it
if they want to they could put forward a
legislation to change it
all right greg and you know kamala
harris has suggested greg in 2019
that we decriminalize on the federal
level marijuana but
if if five people are thrown out because
of past marijuana use i mean how does
she stay in such good spend in the white
house
it's gonna get a security clearance it's
a good question
it's a good question i i sadly i will
never be able to serve in a perino white
house
i don't even know like what i would do
if i had to fill out a form i mean
if i don't lie then will i get arrested
and if i do lie
then will they still will they then come
after me for lying
and from what i understood i thought
these people were told they were told
don't worry about it
don't worry about it yeah so you could
just like yeah and so they just assumed
i'm gonna say i smoke some pot or
whatever and then they lose their job
look
we are being governed right now by
illogical meat puppets right we do not
need to have laws that govern substances
only the abuse of substances and before
you conservative say oh you're a crazy
drug head you can't be pro-second
amendment
then use the same anti-gun argument
against drugs
because it's the same exact argument
individual freedoms
are based on the idea that you can be a
trained law-abiding citizen
i hate this administration for what
they're doing it's not just hypocritical
it is immoral it is immoral to punish
people
for seeking oblivion on their spare time
and it has no effect on
what you do at work i am proof of that
thank you nerd all right thank you greg
juan last question to you
they apparently told people applying for
jobs that it's okay we're going to
overlook marijuana use
and now there seems to be a reverse in
the biden administration a lot of people
are complaining about that
well i'm perplexed too judge because as
i understand i mean obviously
all of us know there are thousands of
people who are working in the executive
branch
and we have five i think what we heard
from jen saki was
there are other factors involved and i
don't know if that involves
lying or hard drug use or some other
kind of
slip up on the person's part but i my
sense is this is not about marijuana
i think that the policy is look we
discourage you from using any illegal
drug
but you know it's not the case that
you're going to be fired for it so i
think something else is going on here
well there would have to be i guess to
have it make sense but then again it
doesn't always
coming